[Music]
when cloud functions 2.0 came out last
month we got access to a whole bunch of
cool new features such as a node 8
runtime custom memory and region
settings and the ability to use
puppeteer in the cloud functions
environment today we're going to put all
these new features to use so we can
server-side render pretty much any
JavaScript application from a firebase
function if you're new the channel like
and subscribe and if you want to get
really good at cloud functions consider
becoming a pro member to get access to
the cloud functions master course so one
of the major benefits of the new node 8
runtime and cloud functions is that it
allows us to run puppeteer and headless
Chrome headless chrome is just a web
browser that can run on your server and
puppeteer is a high level API allowing
you to interact with the browser it's
very intuitive to use and you get direct
access to the Dom on the rendered page
so you can use it for things like web
scraping server-side rendering and to
end testing performance benchmarking and
probably a whole bunch of other things
as well
if we go back to episode 66 we used an
app called render Tron to server-side
render and angular application but one
of the major drawbacks that approach is
that we needed to build and maintain our
own docker container in this video we'll
build an app that's equivalent to render
Tron but on a firebase cloud function
I'm going to be building this function
in an ionic 4 project but you can build
it by itself or with any other
JavaScript framework the cloud functions
back end is completely agnostic to your
front-end if you're in a brand-new
project run firebase and it functions
and then I've selected the typescript
option and it's very important that
you're up to date on the latest version
of firebase tools because all this stuff
is very new from there we'll see the end
of the functions directory and then
we'll need to set up node.js version 8
as the runtime open the package JSON
create an object called engines then set
node to a string value of eight then
another thing you want to do if you're
using typescript is add the Dom Lib to
your TS config this is purely for
tooling and it will just give us
autocomplete on anything related to the
Dom that we're doing inside of puppeteer
and the last piece of setup is to
install puppeteer with NPM
you'll notice that that downloads
chromium which is over a hundred
megabytes in size and chrome in general
requires a higher memory allocation than
the typical 250 megabytes that you would
find in a function so we're going to
beef that up in the next step let's go
ahead and open up the indexed es file
and then we'll import puppeteer in
addition to firebase functions the first
thing I want to show you is how to visit
a page with puppeteer serialized the
HTML to a string then send that as the
response from the function but the first
thing we'll do is set up our function to
run with at least one gigabyte of memory
then after that we can set up our HTTP
function which will be on request giving
us a request and response object which
we can also make an async function the
very first thing you'll do with
puppeteer is create a browser instance
which you can do with puppeteer launch
and then there's a number of different
configuration options that you can pass
in to launch in this case we'll run in
headless mode and I also found that you
need the know sandbox flag for this to
work properly so that's the equivalent
of opening up a browser the next thing
we'll do is create a new page which can
be thought of as the equivalent of a new
tab in the browser and everything in
puppeteer is a sink so you'll notice
that I'm awaiting all of these methods
the next step is to navigate to an
actual URL in this case I'm navigating
to the ionic app that I built which is
just a very simple set of pages when you
navigate to a page it's going to execute
all that JavaScript and you can control
how long puppeteer waits in this case
I'm setting it to network idle zero
which just means it'll wait for network
requests to be idle for 500 milliseconds
and then render the page there at this
point there's all kinds of different
things we can do we might want to scrape
content from the page we might want to
inject jQuery and make manipulations to
it we can take a screen shot and do
pretty much anything else you can do in
a regular web browser but if you just
need the rendered content which is all
we need here we can say a wait page
content and then we'll send that as the
response from this HTTP function now
we'll go ahead and serve this function
and see if it's rendering the meta tags
that we have set up on our front end
application so I'm using an ionic 4 app
here which has an interesting caveat
with web components anything that uses
the shadow Dom is really hard to
serialized back to regular HTML so in
this demo we're only going to use
puppeteer to render meta tags so we can
display our content on social media
sites like Facebook and Twitter but
that's really only a concern if your app
uses the shadow Dom because basically
what we've built here is a proxy browser
that allows us to visit a web page
without technically visiting that web
page on our own browser right now I'm
looking at the rendered content for
angular firebase.com but I never
actually went to this website instead we
went to the cloud functions middleman
which rendered the page with puppeteer
on the server and then sent me that
serialized content as the response so
you basically now have server-side
rendering for any web site on the
Internet
but things aren't quite that simple in
the real world in the full source code
for this project
I've poured it over the render code from
render Tron which handles a lot of the
little things that you'll need to do
when rendering pages things like setting
the base href for your static resources
handling errors loading polyfills for
web components and stuff like that now
the last thing I want to do is rewrite
our functions so we can set up
server-side rendering with firebase
hosting so we'll import the serialize
function from render tron then we'll set
up an app URL which is the location of
where your app is deployed on firebase
hosting or it might be localhost 5004
local testing then we'll write a cloud
function specifically for rendering
pages with puppeteer this first render
function is going to look almost
identical to the one that we just wrote
but instead of using page content we'll
use our serialize method so we have a
little more sophisticated rendering
process and for this endpoint will allow
the render URL to come through as a
query parameter meaning it can be passed
directly through the URL and the
serialize method will respond with the
page content as well as a status code
which we can just go ahead and send back
as the response from this function the
next function we'll write is called SSR
for server-side rendering and we're
going to configure our hosting account
to reroute all requests to this function
endpoint then what we want to do is
determine whether or not the request is
coming from a bot or a human if it's a
bot we're going to want to render all
the content on the server so we have the
meta tags and any other
dynamic content loaded into the page I
have a list of common BOTS here and then
we can see the bots on the request by
looking at the user agent header then
I'll run a filter on our list of bots to
see if there's any from this list
included in the user agent header so if
the length is zero then we know we're
not dealing with a bot but if it's
greater than zero we know that we should
render this page with puppeteer if the
user agent is a bot which would happen
if someone posted this link and social
media then we want to go ahead and
render the page fully with render tron
we can do that by calling the render
function that we created previously that
handles all the puppeteer stuff so we'll
just go ahead and await the response
from that endpoint which should be the
serialized content from the page then we
can take that HTML and send it as the
response body from this function
otherwise we want to just fetch the
route URL from the hosting account and
send that as the response back a single
page application will get this response
and handle the URL client side so it'll
behave just as if the user visited this
page normally on a regular hosting
account you can either deploy this
function or run it locally then at this
point I'm assuming that you already have
a firebase hosting account setup and if
so you'll have it set up as a single
page application that looks something
like this where you're routing the
source to an index.html file we're gonna
go ahead and change that to a function
and have it route to the SSR function
that we just wrote then the final step
is to run firebase deploy which will
deploy both the functions and the
hosting for your client side app and as
a normal visitor to your app you
shouldn't really notice any major
changes but only if you post to a link
bot such as slack or Twitter or whatever
it should intercept that request and
display the meta tags necessary for rich
social media cards so that's how you set
up puppeteer in a cloud function and
we're really just barely scratching the
surface there's all kinds of cool things
you can do one of which is the headless
chrome crawler which is an open source
project built on top a puppeteer that
allows you to iterate over the links in
a web page run jobs in parallel export
to CSV and a bunch of other advanced
stuff I'm gonna go ahead and wrap it up
there if you want to see more advanced
puppeteer content leave me a comment
down below and if you want to take your
development to the next level consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get unlimited
access to all pro content as well as my
full courses and a free copy of my book
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon